you guys chose the kayak adventure hope
you enjoy and don't forget when you want
to choose a new adventure just click
that annotation right up there and it'll
take you back to the menu hello
everybody so we are about to not only to
have a life vests they breeze you hear
what he said no stronger paddlers in the
back definitely taught me how are you
feeling right now Bri pretty good ready
oh yeah strong paddler in the back right
now I'm taking a little break and
Briana's paddling really hard back there
I'm vlogging here I'm gonna try to turn
we've left our kayaks behind and we're
beginning the hike here we work with
flops
oh this is pretty much the coolest thing
I've ever seen that was called sensitive
grass when you touch it it just no Jenna
sighs Boyd fever has died I am gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna get the oxen and I'm
gonna pull him across
success
we still gotta go back raging Rapids not
not our best idea
wonder why your tires totally
appropriate don't worry i'm fillin so if
anybody else follows I'm putting all the
internet
breanne I have impeccable balance a
little cutie normal geckos are just kind
of like skin colored Wow Madagascar okay
free height does pretty good nice and
clean
yeah how's the shoes oh you have any
guess what either
a lot harder than it looks
actually it looks pretty hard hi so
we've made it here to the falls on this
insane Hayek hiking adventure the water
is pretty cold but you know what we're
champions we're champions but I'm gonna
keep telling myself
okay here we go once again fording the
river this time I'm going across this
Oh pull barefoot painful
little brain nature
there's a pig joke on us I do I thought
barreling after me and I thought I was
gonna die
look where's he at hey it was Andrew you
guys all in on that
oh yeah I do nothing Justine I answer
only to Pocahontas we made it back there
were no injuries in the entire time me
and Brandon are issues and we still have
shoes on
yeah kayaking and hiking the lake like
to mouth barefoot and Justine trips and
falls in the first place
breem did a wonderful job patching it up